[Music]
Teddy Walker what brings you back to
Piedmont I'm glad you asked
right now I have an amazing job in sales
but I'm here now taking my GED you would
have to go to night school you're in my
house are you doing the black voice no I
don't hear color good a nice school
teacher no I'm just the [ __ ] that like
to wear blouses yes I'm a nice cool
teacher let's do some introductions hey
yo what up I'm Bobby
he can Skype into the class yeah if
you're doing time at the Georgia
Correctional Facility your next name's
Jalen how about you ma'am I dropped out
of high school so I wanted to get my GED
before they have to live in Randy's
parents laundry room my name is Luis I'm
going to become a singer-songwriter oh
no not like Julio Iglesias
oh it's gonna be a long semester that's
what's up she's not like the teachers
that we had back in the day this woman
is a brick wall school policy if you
don't pass that test
you're out once those tests really you
wear black laundry thing so you wore
yellow it's fresh it's clean my office
what's it look like I'm doing you gonna
take my car my baby in the backs in
there baby in there Wayne Wayne petty
suit you got a lot is dumb as hey I'm
where I'm supposed to be at a fast food
joint next to a strip club must stand in
the right spot
I can smell cocoa butter and fried
chicken at the same time I need you to
go out there and I need you to stop
whether I can't flirt and my day was
innocent now it's all about the but I
heard a guy they I'm gonna crack that
book like a walnut why did you start
there when you want to start in the
front to stop it
it's dances for students only get out my
way [ __ ]
please continue with the Pythagorean
theorem
the issue is you're clinically dumb I
knew it there's no cure for what you
have oh my god I got learning herpes
there's no such thing as learning Herbie
ah you must Muslim we I'm so what what's
going okay why we gonna wait what's the
square root of 81 what what's the square
root of 81 I don't know
[Music]